bevor das video noch nie habe ich noch
eine kleine überraschung für euch und
zwar kommt der neue transformers night
am 22 juni ins kino
und ihr habt die möglichkeit ihn schon
vor allen anderen mit mir am 18.6 in
berlin zu schauen
die dritte von links wieder ich mag mich
einfach nicht fertig richtige schwimmen
so aufregend oh nein das ist nicht meine
stimme verdammt mit mühleberg löwen
kommen wo ich der welt sterben
es gibt 150 x 2 tickets zu gewinnen den
er wird dabei sein und die piper mit
jürgens und die performance und auch
wird voll cool
also wenn ihr dabei sein wollen dann
meldet euch auf das studio 71 seite
links und in der beschreibung an
wir müssen mindestens 16 jahre alt sein
und ja mittwoch deadline 23 59 und das
wird super cool
also ich freue mich das event ist am 18
also macht mit und wenn ihr gewonnen
habt bekommt ihr eine mail von studie 70
also haltet euer postfach im auge und
jetzt wirklich sagen geht es los mit dem
video
viel spaß hallo leute hier wieder einmal
ran und willkommen zu einem neuen
buchbaren video direkt aus meiner küche
ja ich habe veröffentlichter in meiner
küche und super fernseh kräuter und
alles entfernt wie und tumbler aber ich
zeige euch das dann auch wenn es dann so
weit ist wenn die wohnung dann fertig
ist dann werden wir alles sehen bald wie
mein letztes video gesehen habt dann
wisst ihr dass ich die kokosnuss creme
tochter und bei kali gemacht habe und
die werde ich heute essen
das hat mal jemand vorgeschlagen
tatsächlich der meinte dass ich immer
die wie schmeckt lachen ja auch bei mukk
bank seien einfach essen kann und das
finde ich auch eine sehr gute idee
deswegen war das heute und zu trinken
habe ich ein glas wasser
danach verstehen sind gut aus neuer
passt schon
wie immer habe ich mir natürlich auch
notizen gemacht wobei sprechen möchte
also setzt euch hier im haus zu essen
und lasst uns gemeinsam ein bisschen
übers leben sprechen und nur ich spreche
und ihr hört zu
aber statt einzelne kommentare auf dem
herzen liegt ich natürlich durch dieser
kuchen mit mittagsimbiss allerbeste was
bei wie schmeckt beginnt gemacht habe
der schmeckt wirklich so gut so erstes
thema worüber sie sprechen ja bei meinem
letzten sommerloch habe ich gesagt ich
ja auch ein buch herausbringen sollte
und ob die hochbau schläge gehabt und
ganz viele von euch meinten dass ich
einen so schmeckt kochen bringen und das
finde ich eigentlich mega gut also ich
hatte den gedanken schon selber mal dass
ich hier ein kochbuch aussehen könnte
aber ja ich wusste nicht ob das
irgendwie möglich gebaut wird oder das
irgendwie gut ankommt oder auch die
leute sagen warum bringt zum kochen
traut aber da wo viele von euch gezeigt
haben spiele ich echt mit ihm gedanken
wer ganz cool
tatsächlich und dann könnt ihr alle
sachen die schon gekocht hat rein machen
und vielleicht ein paar extra wachen
nicht an danach weiter kochen kann
danach folgten arbeiten von buch zu
schreiben also ich will ja nicht einfach
irgendwie so findet zum beispiel der
teleporter kochbuch ist sehr lieblos
gemacht also da sind die rezepte
halbrunder gillrath und darin aber keine
bilder
das wie seine so schnell irgendwie bye
bye bye keine ahnung wie heißt ein
schreibprogramm luftlöcher braucht man
dafür könnte sein bin mir nicht sicher
wie es ist sagt mir
aber auch wenn der profil arbeiten würde
hätte da schon bock drauf wenn ich das
mal wenn ich mir dass man früher gesagt
hätte dass ich mein kochbuch schreiben
würde
aber wenn ich mich recht machen
koch ich auch wer viel probiert super
super viele rezepte aus politisch im
megaphon patrick pichette glaube ich
jeden dritten tag reis nudeln oder reis
aber smartphones mega gut okay so koch
erledigt viele von euch wollten wissen
wie es jetzt mit meinem nachbarn läuft
der mein tagebuch geklaut hat ganz
ehrlich da habe ich noch nichts weiter
bewegt ich habe meinen hausmeister
zweimal angerufen und zwangen
geschrieben was der doch mal bitte
nachfragen weil dabei behaupten hat den
kontakt zu ihm
man kann ihn besser einschätzen und
deswegen dass er mal im final fragt ob
sich das zurücklegen könnte noch nicht
zurückgemeldet und habe bis heute noch
nicht wir wohnen seit seiner regungen
der offiziell in dieser wohnung und
seitdem hat er unser kleines schild noch
nicht geändert
ich habe jetzt letztens erst mit stift
und papier halt und tesafilm da auch
nicht klingelschilder was andere drauf
geschrieben dass unser name mal ehrlich
wie muss man sofort immer noch mit so
extra namen beschriften damit es halt
immer noch ankommt die kümmert sich um
gar nix ich weiß dass es sich um so
viele häuser kümmern muss aber das ist
keine entschuldigung ich habe noch die
hoffnung also es besteht noch die
hoffnung besucht tagebuch vielleicht gar
nicht in dieser kiste drin war
sondern in irgendeiner anderen aber
jetzt alles durch gesucht und nicht
gefunden
also ich kann mir einfach nicht
vorstellen dass es hier noch irgendwo
ist also muss der nachbar mitgenommen
haben und es muss auch der gewesen sein
weil das alles so gut ich habe einen tag
genau da wo die kiste
ich nehme halt die piste runter oder ein
bisschen papierkram und so umzugskarton
von nutzern gefällt oben alles andere
nachbarin hat die ganze zeit stress
gemacht wie das er bitte unternehmen
sein obwohl auf dieser etage im hausflur
noch ein ganzes sofa von ihr steht hat
wie uns die ganze zettel an die tür
geklebt von wegen dass wir uns darum
kümmern sollen und dass der hausmeister
damit nicht okay ist und bla bla bla bla
bla sondern als die kisten
heruntergenommen haben dann irgendwann
rausgefunden hat so geht wir haben einen
verrückten nachbarn
da habe ich dann an einem anderen tag
halt noch mal mehr papier unternehmen
wollen und wie hoch
irgendwie kam mir das in gedanken so
über nachbar schlägt jemand sparen da
gucke ich noch eine etage also eine
treppenstufe weiter höher und dann liegt
man hat jetzt schon geworden
er hat einen sehr eigenen duft würde ich
mal sagen brauchen karton kleine
handbuch geguckt bin echt wieder so
einfach rückwärts fahren weil ich so
schiffer habe ich gar nicht welche
folgen haben
ja vielleicht in die dampfen zusätzlich
aber ganz ehrlich
meine freundin arbeitet in einer
wohngemeinschaft mit schizophrenen so
gefährlich und wie zufrieden das heißt
ja nicht gleich das du völlig bekloppt
aber sie hat auch gesagt haben
aber es wird schon passen abwehr
zufrieden ist dass er manchmal einfach
nichts oder anderen welt lebt märz habe
die hast du deine handschrift
dass er irgendwie in einer andern welt
lebt da habe ich alles was ist wenn ich
ihn irgendwie unterstelle das emmental
glück lautet und ihnen das dann
aggressiv macht weil er irgendwie einem
acker hat also die geschichten die mir
meine freundin erzählt das wird auch
nicht immer lustig also leute mit nach
kriegen krankheit können gefährlich sein
nicht alle versteht dass ich weiter so
und deswegen irgendwie angst vor ich
werde auf jeden fall eines aufgeben
werde das buch wahrscheinlich irgendwann
wieder kriegen wäre echt schade weil ich
hab' ich habe angst weiter gelesen also
ich weiter so viel wie ihr
ich lese bis dahin wo ich das dann
schneide und bei der lese ich nicht ich
weiß nicht was danach passieren ich will
mich ja auch sehr überraschen
und ja ich will wissen wie es weitergeht
ich kann mich nicht erinnern was ich
damals dann mit elf oder zwölf seinen
gefühlt habe oder was weiter passiert
ist inzwischen haben wir übrigens selber
gebaut
berlin ende sind so hoch gebaut deswegen
sie das auch bei klein wäre
oder eigentlich geht oder zunächst
tiefer sein kleinkindern einem großen
tisch ja umzug verläuft gut
wir lassen uns ein bisschen viel zeit
wir hatten ja die übertrieben wespe
einweihungsparty die man haben konnte
meine mitbewohner haben und ich haben
uns irgendwann so fell ist glaube ich
fahr rannten ideen und und sachen die
wir machen wollten
und dann haben wir werden einen wahren
freund von uns jetzt nicht super fans
weber werden einen barkeeper getränke
hatten wir alles vorbereitet ich hatte
mein zimmer einen kiosk oder meinen
schreibtisch auf meinem schreibtisch
fand ich ganz viele süßigkeiten die man
auch im kiosk kaufen kann aufgestellt
du konntest du mit so einer bunten tüte
und nachfrage kommen zu diesen typen auf
der party zu lang stellen und die dann
halt und tragen wenn man was machen
das war nicht super cool und es gab
guttenberg für die leute die heute nach
hause gegangen wird mit franken bleibt
also ein kleines tetra pak eine
kopfschmerztablette fleisch das man
nicht her
wir waren besser und haben da in jeder
box ungefähr 340 städte geklaut wir
haben uns irgendwann summe also wir
hatten so viele bleistifte bei den nicht
wussten genau wie viele typen wir haben
werden und ohne haben welche abgegriffen
werden so viele kleine schritte als
weiteren erklärt braucht
ich bin eure frau da hole ich mir doch
raten auch ein stück noch ein stück noch
ein stück mehr zum glück einfach
wunderschön geworden und zwar lecker und
schön gesagt aber ich möchte es noch der
drache weil ich spaß habe ich bin hat
mir noch wir hatten den barkeeper und
wir hatten den kiosk gudibergs in
unserem wohnzimmer für noch nicht fertig
gemacht haben also wir haben jeder sein
eigenes zimmer und so kleine wohnzimmer
haben wir noch und da haben wir die
ganze wand mit alu folie beklebt und so
überall für komische licht angemacht und
das war dann wohl der tanzraum es war
auch super cool super cool ja eine gute
sache gab und wir haben einen weg
kameras in der wohnung verteilt und die
leute konnten fotos machen was mit mir
los war es dass wenn das foto zu dunkel
wird dann setzt nicht gedruckt und pilot
kam halb vergessenen blitz an zu machen
aber ja ein paar lustige fotos zeigen
lieber nicht
hier ist die band mit der alufolie a
blind man doch sollte man ein foto das
und schicken die wunderschönsten pamina
termine
ich weiß wie man den tätern haben ganz
viele bilder die ihr nicht die anderen
bilder verächtlich lieber nicht hätten
google einweihungsparty und seitdem
haben wir aber nichts mehr mit der
wohnung gemacht also wir haben halt noch
aufgeräumt und so ich mache mein zimmer
die ganze zeit weiterhin seine möbel
kaufen und irgendwie mich irgendwie
anders da drin haben möchte deshalb so
viel arbeit und ich werde mich also ein
paar tage hin wachsen sondern ich will
halt wirklich ein
zuhause schaffen will ich mich wirklich
wohl fühle und wo alles so ist wie es
mir vorstelle oder wie wir uns das
vorstellen
mach es je nach budget auch meinigen
after school nun wirklich gerne das ist
schöner wenn du nach hause kommst du
irgendwie machen hallo sagen kannst
statt immer alleine zu sein also ich
kann doch verschiedene leute alleine
wohnen möchten aber es ist halt wirklich
alleine wenn du krank bist ist schon im
idee mit dem zweiten stück
[Musik]
ich hab natürlich aber auch was anderes
da meine freundin kitty hat mir nämlich
schokolade mitgebracht aus amsterdam
also aus den niederlanden und die sehen
total cool aus und ich werde die ganze
zeit geschlossen aber irgendwie will ich
auch vor der kamera so toll aussehen
ich hab hier schon eine aufgemacht aber
ein habe ich ausprobiert also probiert
ich habe die hälfte auf gegessen
das ist eine dunkle schokolade mit ford
therme lodge obendrauf
wir kennen hier mittlerweile und
forderten ein klima habe ich noch ein
paar mix mit euch über tattoos sprechen
ganz viele fragen mich von euch ja immer
ob ich meine tattoos machen kann und
kann ich gerne noch mal machen ist
glaube habe ich schon mal einzeln
gewannen etwa q glaubt irrtums
gesprochen aber mehr auch nicht
auf jeden fall habe es morgen ein termin
um mir hier die pocahontas sprechen zu
lassen
ja es ist ein traum von mir glaube ich
seit zwei jahren möchte dieses tattoo
haben und ich raus aber immer kein
tätowierer zu beziehungsweise habe ich
mache es weil ich hab irgendwie schon
geforscht und von diesem natur im kopf
ich habe angst die leute nicht so
hinkriegen werden
nicht nur vorstelle und das wäre sehr
sehr traurig dass verlängern das leben
arbeitet jetzt eine gefunden
die martha und die macht es glaube ich
würde es mir vorstelle ich freu mich
richtig drauf und meine frage an euch
wer jetzt soll ich euch mit der kamera
mitnehmen kann ich dazu flash gleiche
tattoo video machen würdet ihr euch das
interessieren also schreibt mir mal die
kommentare
ansonsten höre ich dann machen und ich
bin da morgen den ganzen tag weil das
wird ein großes tattoo poppig also
möchte und das dauert dann schon so
seine sechs stunden kann das schon
dauern
hab ich schnell wieder beister wo ich
mit links sodass hat eine schokolade die
wicklung aus nicht wunderschön divino
cool aus die niederlande weiter auf
jeden fall wie man schokolade macht die
wunderschön aussieht da sind so was ist
da drin
er hat wer erbt er glaube ich mein gott
es die lücke
sag mir mal ein viertel zum sport gehen
und warum eine fokker honda vernetzter
warum willst du dir zöller einfachen und
stechen lassen weil ich woanders liebe
dieser disney film hat mich als kind
völlig fasziniert also ich bin ja es ist
ein
pocahontas ist für mich die tollste
frauen der welt dieser film berührt mich
jedes mal wieder so hart hat auch ich
nicht erst einmal schauen würde die
verfahren wie sich die ganze zeit dass
wir alle gleich sind und dafür mit
bekämpfen leuten und es ist so finde ich
so toll wenn ich mir die ganzen sprechen
möchte auf meinen arm
ich möchte nicht vergangen das stecken
ich möchte aber dass auf meinem arm
haben kannst du malen wie das
farbenspiel werde es nur fremd wenn der
fremde
ich kann es ging in ordnung
ihr könnt euch gefragt wobei ich noch
sprechen möchte und jemand meint über
disney filme sind für mich immer also
als kind als erwachsener hat die
pinnwand für mich die schönste szene die
es gab sogar das war natürlich immer auf
platz eins unter par als bester film der
rät auch weiter auf dem zweiten platz
gehört für mich glaube ich möchte ich
immer sehr gerne oder mulan haben nichts
miteinander zu tun die beiden aber das
sind nur die beiden nicht richtig gut
waren glaube ich noch ich empfange ich
dennoch ging eigentlich mache ich alles
ich hab keine ahnung was das ist
vielleicht können wir sie erleben barry
entwickeln hat den müll barry google
0-serie maulbeere mit ihrem holtby lässt
kleid das ernährt mich an die ritter
sport trauben muss man sonst nicht so
viel zu erzählen ich bin eine enge linie
in berlin
ich versuche sport zu machen also ich
hab heute ist mir vorgenommen sport zu
machen aber jetzt weiß ich nicht ob ich
das überhaupt noch schaffe und ab morgen
habt dann ein frisches tattoo das heißt
erstmal für zwei wochen keinen sport
also lasse ich das auch erst mal wieder
mit dem sport
es ist nur so dass alle anderen gerade
sport machen
leider macht jeden tag sport kelly nach
dem familientag sport so die macht jeden
tag sport wissen bietet anfühlt wenn du
bei instagram story durch schweiz und
die ganze zeit nur leute wie es die
sport machen und die dann auch keine
lust haben so wie ich aber sich trotzdem
hochlaufen warum zur hölle schaffen sind
nicht hoch zu lassen erzählt mir das
geheimnis kinder
ich würde das gerne auch wissen und seid
ganz gespannt
es kommt nämlich am 16 ein video zu
meinem hammertal experiment raus ich
weiß jetzt haben ganz viele schon
ramadan videos gemacht aber doch egal
ich habe es getestet davon am besten
also stay tuned
oder kommt noch immer noch und nochmals
die schmeckt also ich bin gerade mir ja
motiviert in videos machen das finde ich
richtig gut
also ich hab richtig das gefühl dass ich
wieder auf dem weg der gerne video
machen spinnen und und total viele ideen
einfach umsetzen möchte und das freut
mich
das was man tut auch gerne tut und nicht
so ich muss manchmal wochen wurde videos
produziert und eigentlich überhaupt
keine lust fast alle irgendwie ist es ja
auch ein job wie andere auch morgens
nicht aufstehen wollen musst du ein
tropfen auf stehen natürlich meine
komisch an bei youtube eigentlich bei
mir genauso wie bei ganz vielen anderen
als hobby angefangen hat und wenn dein
hobby zum beruf wird das ist schon
komisch also nur abschnitt und pfingsten
video zu drehen
münchen sie bieten aber wie gesagt du
musst deine miete zahlen und rechnung
die krankenversicherung als steuern so
viel und ich merke dass ich könnte euch
dabei ist noch eine halbe stunde was
erzählt ich habe auf jeden fall dass
euch mein kleines verrücktes seltsames
tasting test mit kokos noch keine tore
gefallen hat mir noch nach oben ich
hoffe mal wieder öfter mode bank zu
machen wir eigentlich dass kohle mit
euch mal direkt zu sprechen und nicht
nach grippe oder irgendwelchen sachen
nicht vorbereitet habt dann einfach mal
zu erzählen werde ich nicht erkennen und
das ist ja gut und schreibt mir einfach
mal was du bei euch los ist die
kommentare und dann würde ich sagen
siehste mal hier könnt ihr mich
abonnieren
vielleicht da so und da ein paar andere
videos ist ein